yeah when he died i was going through so
many emotions for like the
next five years like it was a all kinds
of up and down
um but eventually it just
netted out to i just wanna i want people
to say you know dale jr just added to
the legacy
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show is dale earnhardt jr
obviously dale and i have known each
other for a really long time we drove
nascar together
but actually the first time we met was
back in 2006 for jay-z's show me what
you got music video
that was the first time we met um and
but today was you know and of course we
raced together and i drove for his
nationwide team but today was so much
more about
life you know he shared so much about
his dad and his mom
and growing up racing and that sort of
relationship with him and his dad
and i just felt like today i really got
to know dale jr
well thank you for doing this i really
appreciate it a pleasure yeah yeah glad
you didn't
i didn't think that i would be in this
position of interviewing drivers
yeah it's weird you've been doing a
podcast for a long time though
yeah we started uh we started podcasting
a long time ago um probably eight years
ago
and before it was cool yeah we we got
into it i've never listened to a podcast
and i was like
you know what do we want to get into
podcasting for and someone in my company
mike davis had a vision that this was
going to be a popular platform and it's
worked out
mike's a smart guy he is he's on top of
it
he's been with you forever too yeah mike
started
out as uh kind of my pr guy
he worked he was hired by budweiser back
when i was driving the budweiser car
and um he he'd go the track with me and
just make sure i was on time for my
appointments and all those things and
then i started to see
um you know that he had a lot of
potential and a great vision for
different things and so i thought i
hired him
to work for me and today he's what we
call a brand manager
he tries to help me um expand
you know my profile and my brand and
keep my relationships that i currently
have
working and and and productive but also
get us into other spaces or other areas
and so we created dirty moe media
many years ago on his idea that
podcasting was going to be an important
place to work in and it turned out to be
the right decision
do uh how many do you do a week you do
weekly right
once a week i just came from doing
um my podcast and it takes me about an
hour and a half to two hours
we started out with a with like a 22
minute podcast
and it was just me and another guy
talking about last weekend or what's
coming up the next race
but once i stopped racing we started
having guests and bringing guests into
the show
and um and that's become really fun
because
i'm curious you know i'm curious about
people and and want to
i know what i've heard about them and um
but i want to know more you know there's
so much we today we had ray everham on
as a guest
a creature and car owner and tv
personality in nascar
the guy's just done so much and he was a
race car driver at one point
but we dig into a lot of the
background of of his career that i just
don't know
we never take we never take the time to
sit down and just have these
conversations right
i know i remember when i interviewed the
first interview i ever did was with tony
kanaan
and i actually researched him first
because i was like
you know i got a like 10 pages on him
and
quotes and interviews and statistics and
i thought i know so much more than i
used to know because we as drivers we
don't sit down and go so tell me about
your childhood
which i am going to ask but um you know
tell me about like this and what is your
perspective and what does this make you
feel like we're just like
hey you know it's like tight in three
and four like everyone i do a lift
you know like you're just you know
bullshitting about the car
yeah it is it's so fun to uh
it's so fun to be able to sit down and
take the time to to have those
conversations with people
and you know you just uncovered
i don't know whether you've experienced
this or not i'm sure you have
but when people get into these kind of
conversations
they talk um like we're just hanging out
in a room
and they'll say things and tell you
stories that maybe they haven't shared
with anybody else
or maybe it's just never been in the
right environment to share those stories
and
truths you know about certain uh things
that happen in their lives that
i don't know we call we we we joke that
it's the table in the room that brings
this
truth out and everybody and it makes
everybody so comfortable
about being you know more open in our
podcast
but it's the podcast platform itself
when you get two people just sitting in
a room and or in a zoom call
um they're in a they're in a fun
environment a comfortable environment
and they're willing to
really just have a conversation whereas
typically your interviews that me and
you've done
a million times in our careers they kind
of stay in the lane
you know and we never really reveal too
much but in in this podcast
you can get pretty personal i feel like
now that i'm hearing how long it's been
going on because i know you've been
doing this podcast for a long time but
eight years is a long time
and knowing kind of the you know last 10
year arc of your career
and your life and um
and all the other things too like i'm
even thinking to myself twitter
like when you first started doing
twitter and so
you know of course and maybe some other
people do remember this because i think
it's more of a memory now
but you used to be a lot more private
and like a lot more to yourself
and i don't know if it's secretive as
much as you just like
were much more private and so
do you feel like between the podcast and
twitter
and things like that has that been
something that's helped you open
up because i would think anybody that's
only maybe gotten to know you recently
let's say they're a new nascar fan they
watch you on the broadcast something
like that
like they wouldn't say deal junior seems
like a really like reserved
quiet like shy guy like i would think
everyone would say
he's super friendly he's super relatable
um i really like him and i feel like i
know him
um so has that been a part of it or was
there maybe something else that kind of
made you want to sort of come out of
your shell a little bit more
yeah i've just always felt super awkward
um around people meeting new people
and i get really comfortable once i get
to know people i get really comfortable
and can be
be myself but you know i just
always been really uncomfortable and
awkward
i don't have a lot of social
skills in terms of small talk and chit
chat
and i just don't have that ability to
really come off as
as authentic uh
because of that that awkwardness you
know and so when i when i'm
when i get put in a room with people
that i don't know i just kind of lock
up and um and i'm not outgoing and i'm
not going to take over the room or not
going to be the
life of the party but maybe the fifth
time that i'm at that room or the
you know i might be that person you know
it just takes me a while to sort of
get comfortable and and trust um
the environment and the people i'm
around uh
and i feel like that uh the things you
mentioned the podcast twitter
really accelerated all that stuff
twitter and you know
gave me a real great platform to
to experience uh with how people reacted
to
certain things and it was also
obviously if you're a race car driver
you have great days you have bad days
it's a great place for to go to get
people to put pick you back
up off and put you back on your feet
after a bad run but it's also a place to
go celebrate something great
um but it was really uh um
i know that i have to remind myself that
that twitter or
instagram is a is just the tip of the
iceberg it's not the entire
public opinion of you or or
the perception of you but it is an
important
sort of uh a personal
sort of place to test and experience how
people are going to react you know and
how people feel about you
um so that's been really interesting to
me
i learned a lot from twitter i had a lot
of great experiences
in twitter instagram those were probably
my two go-to
social media platforms the podcast has
given me a chance to
the reason why i really enjoyed the
podcast at first
was because i controlled the context of
the conversation my
my comment or whatever if i'm going to
talk about something i don't agree with
uh particularly in nascar um
i i you know you i could send you to the
podcast to get the context the tone
the inflection of the of the comment
whereas
when i would for years you know you know
a decade or more
in the 2000s man your your comments and
quotes could just get taken
so out of context yeah and people would
read it and they would
hear it many different ways some guy
might think he said something positive
where someone else might read the same
thing
and think you said something negative um
and that's
uh that's where the podcast sort of gave
me the ability to
say how i feel and people understand
where i'm coming from with no
confusion i really enjoyed that i don't
use the podcast
like that anymore now that i'm not a
driver i just love to hear people tell
their stories
we still get a little opinionated
sometimes on the podcast
but um they're just you know i i was
just always really shy
awkward uh
you know introverted hi you know i
give me a video game
and i'd hide in a room all day long uh
you know and just never want to go to
dinner or never want to go
we would go to these race tracks all
across the country all the way
all through the 2000s all the way up
until i met amy really
uh we'd go to these race tracks and
danica i'd never leave the racetrack i'd
never leave the bus
uh when me and amy started dating she's
like i'm like hey you're gonna go to the
racetrack with me it's gonna be awesome
we get there and she's like are we not
leaving this bus
like we were there for like 24 hours at
pocono or somewhere and i'm like no
why would we leave we have all the food
we need
uh i'm here to race i'm at the racetrack
i can't leave the track it's like
seven o'clock at night and i'm like i
can't leave what i've never left
why would i leave and she's like i'm not
sitting in this bus all weekend we're
going to dinner find somewhere to go
where can we go and uh that was so
foreign to me you know i i just said i
wasn't one
i wasn't nothing nothing kind of
propelled me to go
outside of my comfort zone and then amy
you know along with other things we
mentioned amy was a big she forced it
she's like
look you're i'm not living this way
you're going to have to
want to go out and do and enjoy and
experience
um and and she made it a lot of fun you
know she showed me a whole
i hate it's almost embarrassing to say
she showed me a whole
sort of new lifestyle of getting out and
just doing that's beautiful
um i want to talk about amy in that
whole part of your life now which is
your everything with
isla and another girl on the way and
family but
going back to saying how
you know just introverted and shy and
uncomfortable in a room
have you ever figured out where that
comes from
you know i think it everything sort of
comes from your childhood
i had a you know
from the outside looking in and if i
really
you know if i really think about it i
had a very good
i had a lot of great breaks as a child
and a
teenager and had a lot of opportunity
um i really did i i
i'm not going to complain one bit about
the position
or the situation but it wasn't always
perfect
my parents got divorced in 78.
uh i lived with my mom never saw
dad i've got like one or two kind of
memories of dad before i was
probably sixer or um i don't really know
how much he was around
or how often we were able we were sent
to
be with him you know like if he got
visitations i don't know when he got him
or how often he got him or how often he
took his opportunity to do that
i don't have a lot of memory of that and
i was living with mom in a time in a
real small house in kannapolis
and woke up one morning the house was on
fire and
big time on fire and so i
mom's boyfriend comes into the bedroom
and he's like hey get on get your pjs on
we got to get out of here
and i'm like uh i'm you know just kind
of waking up and i'm like i don't know
what's going on but i get my pjs on and
i walk out of my bedroom and i look to
the right and the whole kitchen is just
a big wall of fire
craziest thing i've ever seen in my life
i mean you know you you
never forget some things like that but
we walk outside and the next thing i
know
i'm standing you know day or two later
i'm standing in dad's garage at lake
norman in mooresville
and all our stuff's in there all our
stuff's in the garage and
uh we're gonna live with dad uh so
mom was broke and had to move back to
norfolk virginia to be
uh closer to some family there
that was the decision she made she
couldn't afford
uh it was just going to be too hard on
her
to contain uh to maintain me and kelly
and and
she had no job or nothing at that time
and so
we went to live with dad i didn't know
dad i didn't know theresa
she was there and part of dad's life at
that point um
and that was a hard thing me and theresa
when i was a kid
man we butt heads hard um
you know we were sprung into her life
she wasn't
you know she was with dad and thinking
man i've got this vision of the future
and boom here comes
these two kids from his previous
marriage that are just now
okay gonna you know we're gonna just
plop into the household and
she's gotta adjust her expectations of
her future with dad i understand her
frustration with that
um but me and kelly you know kelly and
me we just tried you know
it was weird there was a lot of good
amazing things that happened because now
i'm with dad i get to
get to know him get to go to the races
it was an
amazing experience to be going to race
tracks and
enjoying all those things but um
and then when you go to school so we'd
go to school
and you would think that man you know
your dad's dale earnhardt and
everybody's gonna go wow that's cool
you're
you're cool because your dad's cool but
it wasn't like that you know it just
people
the kids i was going to school with uh
didn't
think it was cool you know and that
didn't create advantages for me like you
might think
uh and i was a uh i was
uh i had like two or three four friends
you know in in school
um i knew a lot of people i mean you
know just trying to think back on my
my high school days i just was it
i don't know i wasn't outgoing and and
wasn't one to strike up a conversation
and i was real real quiet and
i think it just kind of created this
sort of uh
this this sort of sustained
um personality and and approach to life
um all through you know my teenage years
we went to a lot of different schools i
ended up getting sent to military school
for
a couple years i was in a christian
school got in big trouble there
talking talking in class and just doing
stupid stuff you know being in being a
clown
um man when i went to christian school i
did kind of come out of my
shell for a minute i was only there for
half a year for whatever reason
the other kids in that school were like
me they weren't perfect
you know and and and i could see myself
in them and they
accepted me and that was the first time
i think in my school
career as a child feeling like i was
around people like me you know
and and they were all kind of there
because they needed to get straightened
out a little bit
um but i think they're being around
that environment made me act out more i
was so excited to be around
people that enjoyed me and thought
that i was a fun friend and all those
things and so i started being goofy
and then i got in trouble talking in
class too much and doing other things
and i had to go to military school but i
ended up finishing
my high school career at mooresville
senior high back home and i left school
i went to a uh technical college
uh to get an automotive degree i never
aspired to go to a four-year college
didn't ever look at a uh you know
applying anywhere my grades were crap
i just assumed that i was never going to
go to any big school
i didn't want to leave home i wanted
race
dad said that he would help me get into
racing if i continued to
achieve more in school beyond high
school so
i got an automotive degree i started uh
you know started working at a dealership
his dealership changing oil and things
like that but i was
i just was awkward and uncomfortable for
most of my life you know i was the kind
of guy that
i liked nirvana and pearl jam and that's
okay well i know i'm just saying like i
was
i felt like this out this misfit you
know what i'm saying this
like i didn't belong to a certain thing
i wasn't popular
i wasn't trendy um
i don't know it was it was a it was a
strange time but um
when you were a kid were you know these
are like
subjects that i dive way deep into now
about personalities and attachment
styles
and all kinds of kind of just
understanding
who we are as people and really what
what how we overcome our childhood
that we want to overcome right because
we don't want to overcome all of it we
just
the parts that hold us back right so i'm
thinking that
we're you know just not being you not
wanting to be seen
makes me think that you didn't feel seen
as a kid
is that true like feelings
you know just being around being you
know
someone that they want around yeah maybe
not necessarily want but just like
like you were important yeah that was
when i went to
the christian school um i
i don't i never felt like uh appreciated
like i did when i was around those that
group of kids and i don't know
why it was different or what it was but
i instantly i was a new kid those other
kids have been going there for a couple
years you know how that is
but they took me in and i was i was
i was just i fit right in i just kicked
right in there and
i was loving it um
and then after that i don't think i've
attained that sort of
interaction with people since you know
and
uh dad was such this that was just this
sort of
blue collar tough rugged
uh man's man you did every you know you
just wanted so badly for him to
appreciate something you did or thought
something you did was
cool or or um he was so
hard to impress and just always just
thinking about work and work and work
and
gone working going all the time even
when he wasn't racing on the weekends
when he was home during the week he was
at the farm or at the shop working
you never saw him and so when he'd come
home
he plopped down in the lazy boy in the
kit in the living room and fall asleep
like eight
nine three nine o'clock at night you
there was no sort of
time to be with him and uh
and so you know i didn't know it then
it wasn't bothering me then it bothers
me now you know that that it was like
that because he's gone
um and i can't make up for it but
when i was a kid it just it was just the
way it was you know it was just the way
things were and you didn't
i wasn't i didn't think it was bad it
was just the way things were but looking
back it's like man
i hate that he wasn't more proactive
uh but he you know he made up for it
when taylor was born um his daughter
uh with theresa he was an amazing father
and i think that he knew
that he that he needed to be you know
and he needed to be more
you know uh a part of her life and so i
got to see what he was capable of
as a dad um to you that hurt your
feelings
no i mean i was jealous in the moment in
the moment i was certainly jealous
you know but as an adult growing up
um you know
as i know that you know we all lost him
you know
so taylor lost him
taylor taylor hurts the same way i heard
over it
um you know that so there's
you know we have that in common and so i
you know i i'm no longer really jealous
of that experience that they
had because it was so short in in her
life
how old were you uh
26 or 8 or something when she was born
no when she was born shoot um that
i can't only know 12 10 12 maybe
so did that was that a point in time
where you felt like
you know you could see what he could be
like as a dad
but did that help him be a better dad to
you too then at that point
well i think i don't know what triggered
my relationship but as soon as i started
to
race um competitively
uh we really got to to having more
conversations
and and he got he got to focus in or
spending a little more time around us
you know he wanted to make sure our car
was safe he wanted to make sure we
he didn't care how we did it he wanted
us to just go out and screw it up
and learn from that but he you know he
wasn't sort of hovering over us while we
were trying to race i'm talking about me
and my brother carrie we shared a car
together
um but he wanted to make sure it was
safe make sure the motor was
not going to explode and all those
things
so we got to spend a lot of time with
him when we started racing and the more
success i had with racing and as i
started
as i started to become a part of his
team's future at dei as
when i started to win in the xfinity
series man it was a light switch
i had said this before so this is not
new but for most of my
uh teenage years i felt like i was a big
disappointment
um i told you my dad was a man's man
tough big
uh rugged and i wasn't i was the
opposite in my mind and i was sensitive
and quiet and shy and not a assertive or
not an attack i didn't attack a plan or
or
or really have a you know an original
thought of my own
at any point and so i didn't know how to
start my career
i wanted to race badly had no clue how
to get started
uh and i didn't attack that you know and
and i felt like that i wasn't
living up to his his hopes uh
and so when i started racing and doing
well it was like a
i mean a 180. here i am
doing something that he didn't know that
i was capable of doing
i knew i was shocking him um
and i was shocking myself but um
i was blowing his mind he's sitting
there going holy moly i might have
you know i gotta i gotta i gotta get
involved in this
and contr make sure this goes the right
way this kid's got a real shot
i want to make sure it's he doesn't get
screwed over and doesn't get
you know gets gets the right chances
here and so right away you know as soon
as we started running well in the
xfinity series right around 1998
he um we were right there together
we did commercial shoots together photo
shoots together
um we didn't talk like racing like hey
drive this way drive the track this way
we're coming up on this track let's sit
down and discuss it
yeah but we you know he would talk to me
in broader terms of
you you need to be on time you need to
be ready you need to have you know you
need to get your hair cut for this photo
shoot coming up and this is where you
people expect you to be and act and talk
and
i got um we got to talk we got to spend
a lot of time around each other
in in 98 99 2000. it was incredible
yeah i mean to have those three years
now to look back and go like
yeah that's how you always wanted it to
be that connection
but which is so beautiful i mean
imagine if you would have never got that
time you know so there's something to be
grateful in it for sure but
it makes me think that you know because
when he started to do well is when he
started to pay attention
and so how did that look
after he passed did you have a real
association with
being to own you could only be could you
only feel proud or good
if you were doing well was that
something you you you dealt with
afterwards right before he passed away
um i don't know two months six months it
was in the
in the last year i was writing a column
[Music]
for a racing publication that was pretty
popular
um in the industry and it was a it was
like winston cup scene
um they everybody was everybody would
read it it would get passed out at the
racetrack and
um so i was writing a little column for
that just to have some i like to
write and express and um
yeah so kind of like just the you know
the podcast or anything like that just
kind of telling my side of the story and
storytelling i'm writing these
blurbs just about what's happening in
the racing
industry nothing crazy one night for
some reason i sat down
by myself and i wrote this sort of essay
about dad
and what he meant to me and i
really it took me no time at all to
write this and it just poured out with
so
much ease and i was extremely proud of
it
and so i was like i'm gonna take this
and i'm gonna
publish it in this artic this thing and
and everybody's gonna read it
everybody's gonna know how i feel about
my dad
but i was scared to do it without asking
him you don't do anything about dad with
dad with his use of his name or anything
without going to him and saying is this
okay
so i asked him if i could see him for a
second he's up in his office at dei
i go up there with that piece of paper
and i said hey i got this thing i wrote
and i want it's about you
i want to put it in the windscreen scene
in a couple weeks and i just need to
make sure you're okay with it and he
grabs
he takes it and he reads it and he
stands up he starts walking around
reading it and it's only you know about
a page
uh and uh
he stops at the end and he takes a
minute
and he says you know we never tell each
other how we feel about each other but i
read in reading this i know exactly
how you feel and
i was like yeah i was like man that's
exactly how i feel about you
and i'm i didn't know you didn't know
that you know that i didn't that i
thought you were this great
amazing thing and he was like i'm so
glad you did this
i'm so glad you shared this with me
we're having these like he doesn't talk
this way
and so looking up over here so i'm glad
you're talking
it was amazing um and so
he's like you can't use this in this
this publication you gotta
you save this for a book or something
i'm like no i'm not saving this this is
how i feel right now and i want
everybody to know it
so i'm gonna put it out there and
i did um and so
but anyhow i i think had that not
happened
had i not had that that moment was
is the most important moment in my life
with my dad without a doubt we won races
together
and stood in victory land together but
to you know to know that he
knew how i felt about him is really
important because you know knowing that
he would pass away many months later
so months later after that right yeah i
mean it was within the year
so had i never got to share that with
him man that would be tough going the
rest of my life
wondering with if you know i don't know
what
you know i don't know
you know not knowing i don't know if i
ever see him again right
everybody believes what they want to
believe and and i kind of
have my beliefs um and i don't know what
they are sometimes i don't know what to
believe or what to expect
but if i if i was to never cross paths
with him again
and and he leave this world without me
really knowing
not not being able to share that with
him would be so hard it would i would be
so
i'd be in such a harder place and
spending all these
last 20 years without him it would be so
difficult had i not had that chance so
i'm glad that happened it was just as
you know as
a sort of spur of the moment thing um
you know so i feel very lucky uh
and and to answer your question about
beyond his death how was
how was how was uh
what was winning or succeeding and what
was the motivation of that
um at that moment you know beyond his
death it was
it was more about just adding to the
legacy like
you know when i would go to daytona he
won 36 races at that race track across
iraq and
and the bush national series and cup and
all that right so 36 races
and anytime i won there whether it was
in an xfinity car
in the cup car anything that i ever won
at that race track i just was it was
like
putting another mark on the wall in the
earnhardt column right
um and i just wanted
i knew that i wasn't going gonna win
seven championships i knew i wasn't
gonna win
83 races or however many races he won 76
whatever it is
i knew i wasn't going to do all those
things i just wanted to like add
to i wanted to add to that earnhardt
name and the earnhardt legacy
and i thought you know if i can do that
he'll be real proud of it
um i know that he would be proud of it i
know that he would also tell me
all the all the areas where i could have
done better um
but you know that yeah dad's do that
so but i i wasn't really motivated to
like when he died like i'm you know i'm
going on and on and on here but
it's good that's what it's for yeah when
he died i was going through so many
emotions
for like the next five years like it was
a
all kinds of up and down um
[Music]
but eventually it just netted out to i
just wanna
i want people to say you know dale jr
just added to the legacy whether it was
added a lot or added a little it didn't
matter but i just wanted to be able to
add to it he
he's the reason why anybody knows that
last name and i just wanted to make
sure that i didn't squander that or ruin
that or
or stain that legacy you know i wanted
to be able to
to improve on it a little bit i feel
like that that letter made you won
instead of two different people you
it feels like there was a um
there was like a merging of
love yeah i feel like that we were
definitely
becoming getting on the same page yeah
and we were certainly getting on the
same page personally
and professionally you know and i think
as i got older
had he lived we would have really worked
in tandem um to achieve whatever
it was that we wanted to achieve and and
um so that was it was good that that was
happening you know because it for the
longest time and we were so
disconnected he was he was on a mission
and i didn't fit that i didn't i didn't
try to fit that i didn't try to i didn't
we didn't connect we just didn't have a
relationship you know it was it was
a lot of father and sons relationships
are complicated
father daughter ones are complicated too
but yeah it's not the hardest thing when
you're young
is to having on any kind of
understanding
that it's not your fault it's not about
you the way that they touch you
like my dad was extremely hard on me he
yelled at me
he was i mean every weekend i recently
found out it was
every single weekend went to the track i
got yelled at
and it was like how did you get over it
and you know how did we get beyond it
and
mom's like well we gave in and i was
like
well now i know i am a fixer you know
like there's a lot to unpack in that but
it's impossible when you're a kid to
have any kind of understanding that
okay got it the way you treat me is a
lot more about you than it is about me
that doesn't feel like that
no it doesn't yeah yeah doesn't it
i think once i got older i started you
know
not to let dad off the hook but i
certainly understand
why he chose the even the bad decisions
why he chose to do what he did you know
when i was young i didn't understand
when i was younger i didn't understand
why he wasn't more
um like he wasn't at my graduation
he pushed so hard for me and kelly to
finish school he quit school in eighth
grade
he met he failed so many times that he
was 16 years old in the eighth grade
and he finally gave up and quit yeah and
so
all through my high school years
he's like you got just you got to finish
your school i don't know why you thought
we were going to drop
out but he's like i just need you to
finish school i just want you to finish
real important to me that you finish
school if you guys even try to go beyond
high school and get more education i'll
really be inclined to help you
achieve whatever you want to achieve it
was really important to him we get there
for graduation and he's at a racetrack
you know and i understand you know that
yeah what is your understanding now you
say you understand but
i do not understand how he missed my
graduation because he had the means to
travel
but yeah i um that that frustrates me
but
i understand i guess why he was so like
in the 70s when i was born
all the way till you know we basically
were
were putting his lap at 81 when our
house burnt down he didn't come
to you know acquire uh
custody of us that just happened by
circumstance
and you know so but but he wasn't
he didn't go out of his way i guess to
[Music]
um to be a bigger part of our lives when
we were really young and his focus was
just trying to make it you know he was
eating
bologna sandwiches and tomato sandwiches
and
uh working on cars till four in the
morning and
getting up and going to jobs and working
a real job and then working all night
long on the race cars and doing what he
thought he had to do
is that what his dad did his dad
had a little his dad had a little better
of a system
um and he was a better family man um he
had a bigger family and took
and seemed to be a better father a
little more part you know a little
a little better at being a part of all
their lives um
[Music]
you know dad got around to it but um he
was selfish
you know when he was young uh
and him and mom you know it's a it's
complicated but um
i i uh i'm glad that it turned
you know one day and and our
relationship
uh improved and i could become yeah
i could be you know it was a big deal to
be able to get to where me and him could
sit down and have a conversation and
talk about some that was another moment
um
that was pretty impactful between me and
dad
so i was racing in 1997
i was racing one-off xfinity races here
and there
i had a car and i took it to charlotte
and we were practicing on friday the
race is uh
the next day and i crashed in practice
and it was the only car i had so we load
up and we go home and i'm upset and i'm
disappointed and i thought my career was
over
i really in that moment like i crashed i
embarrassed myself
embarrassed everybody dad all in front
of his peers and everything
and so i probably won't get another
chance like this
and i go home and i sit in my house and
i'm sulking
and like two three hours later dad comes
home he's done it
he's done at the racetrack so he's come
back home which is
just a few miles away comes banging into
my door
and did you start yeah
well he stomps in there in his cowboy
boots and
he looks at me and he goes what are you
doing and i was like well i wrecked i'm
i figured i'm done i don't know i'm just
sitting here
feeling sorry for myself he goes come
here and we go outside and we had this i
was living in a double-eyed trailer and
there's
concrete steps on the back porch and we
sit down on them steps and he's like
he's like the guys that are helping you
on your car just some friends of mine
they're over at the shop cutting your
car apart to fix it
i was like really he's like yeah he's
like why aren't you over there that's
what you should be doing if you want to
race again you should be wanting to fix
the car you just wrecked
and i was like it didn't dawn on me to
do that i thought it was over i thought
my life
my career was over and we had like a
two-hour conversation on them steps
about you know just about doing the
right thing or
he's like man when you crashed you know
i understand being disappointed and mad
but why wasn't why wasn't your next
instinct
to fix this car what have i got to do to
get it fixed what do i got to do to get
back out there and do it again
like that should be your you should you
should nothing you know you should be
jumping over every fence or hurdle in
your way to get to that next opportunity
instead of yeah instead of sulking and
that's what he did that's who he was he
could do that
so what was his greatest lesson then
like if you can look back and you think
man
thank god for this because it's changed
my life
um i think that that moment right there
that was the first time me and him had
ever had one of those talks
um about
you know just uh you know
we never had conversations about life
and just trying to do you know how to
achieve and how to what what's the
attitude to have and how
how should you be approaching things we
just never had those conversations
so that was really the first time that
we sat down and i was like i felt like
man he's in my corner
he wants me to to succeed you know
and i felt like for the longest time in
my racing career he was like
nervous to give me opportunities
because he was like i you know he if
this goes real bad i don't you know
i don't know that's i i felt like he
we got you know we got to race late
models we got to do a lot of cool stuff
me my sister my brother and dad created
those opportunities for us
but his involvement in it was so lacking
like he wouldn't you know he wouldn't
come in there and say
man you need you need to set your car up
like this he just i just set it up
you know and went to the track and it
run or it didn't run
and his so the fact that he wasn't so
more hands-on made me wonder whether he
really
was interested in helping us get all the
way up to the top right
totally that's a natural that's a
natural reaction to someone
kind of feeling like you feel like well
honestly you kind of reciprocated he
gave a half-assed attempt so you kind of
did
yeah in a way right like you're like
well i guess it's over because you're
like
you know you're not seeing him display
the kind of commitment that you needed
to have
too right it's a confusing
yeah it's a fine balance because i don't
you don't want them to be
overbearing and over your shoulder and
pushing and pushing pushing
but that was the complete opposite he
was like
okay um take this race car to the track
good luck
and i'm like i know i don't know nothing
about setting this thing up and making
it go around the track i can drive it
but i don't know how to make it go fast
uh that sounds like me i'm like i don't
even know where the track bar is on that
thing but i know it
does yeah i mean i i learned a
tremendous amount with that approach
yeah but i didn't know he was really in
my corner like
i didn't know that his heart was in it
that his heart wanted to see us win and
see me go far
until we had that conversation on that
back porch on them steps
that's when it dawned on me like oh
i get it like you want me to win and the
reason why you're kind of hard on me and
the reason why you're kind of letting me
leave me out on that island to flounder
and learn
is because that's the way you feel like
it's the best approach for me and best
way for me to succeed but
in his heart he really did really does
want me to con
to continue this to achieve more to try
to strive for more
he was so i think he was really worried
about people's perception of helping us
helping me and kelly and kerry because
he would always say in interviews and
stuff
i ain't helping them they're going to
have to want to do it they're going to
have to want it
they're going to have to go out and get
it they're going to you know i'm not
he wasn't going to be that you know dad
that
that did everything for you and hired
you the best crew chief to
take you to the track and make sure your
car was super fast
um he wanted you to be able to take
credit for what you did
yeah we'd go the racetrack oh i raced
against this guy
named robert powell and he won every
single week
i'd run second and i'd come home and
working on my car dad walks in monday
morning
where'd you run i run second to robert
it's a good good night but robert won
and
one night we won and
robert wasn't there right but we won
i get the trophy come home i put the
trophy on top of the lance cracker
machine
because i know that's the first place
dad's gonna go when he walks in the
doors to the cracker machine
and so the trophy's up on top of this
cracker machine and i cannot wait for
him to walk in there and see it
and i haven't been able to tell him i've
won a race ever right
he comes walking in 10 o'clock in the
morning or so
and he walks up crack sheen and i was
like and he don't say
anything and i was like dad look at that
trophy look at that trophy man
and he's like y'all won and i was like
yeah he goes
robert wasn't there was he i was like oh
my god who cares
i'm telling you he just grinned as
earnhardt grin and walked out the door
oh my god
i felt like so let down um
he was a hard hard hard tough dude
but you know what was funny is he would
walk out of the building
go go 100 yards down down the hallway
into somebody else's room and go y'all
won't believe man junior won the race
this weekend
so cool you know and and i'm hearing all
this stuff now
right from all his friends oh he used to
love talking about you
she loves you know he's so proud of you
so proud of you you know but he could
not ever bring
himself to to he just was so worried to
keep too much praise on you
and he wouldn't die hard enough yeah
that's i i can relate to that
that that's happened in my own dynamic
with my dad like
that's a criticism over the last few
years even it's just you know
he'll go tell everyone else like so
proud of this they're so great so glad
for that how about this
you check this out and then here i am
getting nothing
like there's no appreciation there's no
um you know he doesn't praise me and so
you know i've had this sort of feeling
my whole life of not being good enough
or not being enough because i didn't
really get that
but i think the same thing i think he
comes from this
hard knocks tough mentality of like
you know i gotta build you strong i
gotta build you determined i gotta make
you
want it you gotta you know i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna let you feel like this is
enough like when we go go-kart racing
and i'd be
half a second quicker than everyone um
that was
never good enough honey that even wasn't
good enough i was you know half a lap
ahead at the end
and that wasn't good enough like so i've
always had this feeling too and it's
frustrating but
you know the the extraction is that
you do try hard and you do really push
yeah and you do accomplish great things
because
you didn't just and you did
add to the earnhardt name but you had
your own incredible career on your own
that needs to be said yeah well i
appreciate that i i will i always
said too interesting enough that
those years in the late model car in the
in the sort of when i was getting
crafting you know
cutting my teeth and learning the ropes
were some of the
most fun years going going to the track
with no real guidance
was actually so exciting
uh the fear uh and the anxiety
anticipation
uh when things worked the six you know
you knew you were the reason why it
worked
um i mean i had plenty of good friends
helping me but none of us knew more than
the other
yeah and we all kind of well kind of
enjoyed that you know not having
somebody go this is the way it's done
y'all do it that way and we're doing it
this way
it was better to go just trial and error
we didn't have as much success
i didn't have really any any success in
late models before i got into xfinity
series
but i learned more in those three years
just
you know being so hands-on um and i
always say i always feel like man
i if i could go back to any part of my
career to relive it it would be those
those days in the late models just going
up down the road with your buddies uh
having fun racing yeah there's a lot of
fun that does get taken out of it
you know we can both sit here and be
like you know
if i had to do another friggin interview
if i had to do another damn media day
before the season started
another whatever day another this
another are you happy to be back at
kansas speedway day and you're just like
oh
can't you guys just come up with
something original and then you know all
the [ __ ] that goes along with it you
know and
um the politics of it all and
you know you know how it goes it takes
the fun out of it and i think back too i
mean like go-karting was the
funnest right like it was a fun time
um you know you you
you know you talk about your dad's the
letter you wrote to your dad and you
talk about the lesson about
effort and i can't help but think like
and wonder
how how did that how did that
spill out into your life from there on
out did you
did it change the way you approach your
meaningful relationships your
friendships your
um your relationships your you know
family
because you recognize just how powerful
truth
was um did anything did that affect did
you think about that or was that more
just something that you can take away
as a a really meaningful thing that
happened with your dad
i just feel like that the the
opportunity to be able to share with him
how i felt about him
was it was a very uh stroke of luck you
know
we were we weren't going to take that
time to sit down and really have that
conversation
and i've um encouraged a few friends of
mine
and even that want to have that same
conversation with somebody else to write
that letter
and it's just it really was what broke
the ice it really
was what i it said it better than i
could have said it verbally
because i would have screwed that up um
and the letter made dad listen
whereas if i was just walked in there
and told him i don't know that he'd
heard it
the same way so um have you uh have you
written a like a letter like that to
anyone else have you written that letter
to your wife amy
nothing like that one but i will one day
that's probably a good idea
but um see your daughter your daughters
you know i've always thought about
i've always thought about doing that um
what writing what either maybe even just
making a video
uh for my for my girls now
uh might do for them down the road
you know when they're when they're older
um
my i'm 45 so i started young having kids
my mom just recently passed away
at 67 and so you know my dad's
death didn't have a real
impact on my uh
approach to life or or i was young and
there was a lot in front of me
and so um it impacted me in a lot of
ways but it didn't do what my mom's
death did and when my mom passed away
this past
year man it really messed me up
really uh yeah it uh
it made me really scared about
how much time i have left and so
especially when i look at my daughters
and i go man you know
i want to be here a while and i don't
want to just suddenly leave them at a
very young age and
you know i worry too much and if that's
not evident already by the end
by this point in the interview i'll just
admit it that i just
i just you know worry i worry way too
much about things but
i i really got to thinking about that
like i need to take better care of
myself or if there's anything i can
change in my lifestyle that might help
me
i quit smoking probably 10 years ago i
used to smoke
every day a pack a day wow
for years i hid that from everybody i
used to
um well matt kansas jokes around me and
him part
me and him used to be parked next to the
racetrack every weekend with our buses
and he used
he uh it was like this sort of secret
that everybody knew
you know because i'd be smoking in the
bus and i had this fan and it'd pull all
the smoke out of this one particular
window
and matt's like man i just sit there and
watch the smoke coming out of that truck
that bus all weekend and i'm like man
you never said anything he's like well
what's to say you know
and um you know i i smoked when i drank
uh and then it became a habit every day
all day and uh
so my mom smoked too and she died of
lung cancer and
um and i talked to her about that you
know uh
but it put a fear in me that um
man i don't know how much time i got
left maybe it's uh
20 years maybe it's 40 years who knows
but
i'm going you know it made me really
realize i guess how precious
uh life is but it that impacted me
and made me um you know made me really
try to enjoy my girls and
and and appreciate what i have my
marriage
um but yeah i don't know it
it still bothers me now i mean it was
recent so
i'm still not quite sure you know that
i'm
that i'm through the through the woods
but uh
yeah my dad's death was so sudden that
um i don't know if it didn't have it
didn't have
the effect that i think a lot of people
might imagine it had
whereas with my mom watching cancer do
what it did to her
just was awful
and and it and you knew what was coming
you know that that was a incredibly
different experience than
losing dad so suddenly but uh
so there there's uh i don't know i i
i came out of dad's passing and just
i got wild and and clubby
yeah we we raised hell and had fun and
we raced
and we tried to do everything we could
just to keep marching forward
and and you know and then you know
ended up having a pretty reasonable time
and and success in racing and
and then like i said just recently my
mom passed and it sort of reset the
stage if you will
like what's important in life and and
damn you better
appreciate what you got while you're
here and um
you know be everything you can to the
these two little girls that i got and um
try to be a good husband and you know
just uh enjoy it golly because it's
short as hell
yeah and can be shorter than you expect
yeah it could be what are you gonna do
different what's on your list what's on
your bucket list
like i wouldn't like to call it bucket
list i like to call it
like more of a life list because yeah
you know when you do them
you should feel alive right we're not
doing them to check a box off
to die like we shouldn't think about
dying we should think about living like
what's your live list
me and amy really got to traveling um in
the last couple of years before
we had our first little girl and since
we've had eyelashes kind of shut down
uh some of the some of the broader trips
we wanted to take
i went to australia back around 2005
2006
and i want to take amy there so bad i
made some great friends in australia
and just i love their approach to life
and so i i'd love to take amy down there
for a trip i've never been to new
zealand i hear it's amazing
um yeah so i there's other parts of
europe that i'd love to experience
we've been to germany a couple times but
um never been to ireland or
or or england or anywhere like that so
i just want to see all of the world i
want to go to
i want to go to alaska i've never been
to alaska
um so there's i'll be
sitting i'll be sitting on the couch or
in the bed before dinner
before we go to sleep sort of googling
these random places
all over the world that are not the not
the big cities
but the small towns that sort of uh
surround them
um like when we went to germany we went
to
we went to towns that were like 300
people
uh very small places to get a real
authentic understanding of
what life is like in that space you have
german background do you have german
are you german yeah yeah i traced my uh
genealogy back to
a particular town in germany and
yeah we went there i was i wanted to go
i traced um some i traced some of my
family back to this
particular church and it was in a small
town called ilvestheim
and and uh 300 people lived there in
1700
and 300 people lived there today it's
not really changed a bunch
and so yeah and it's the church is still
there
and um i read the so i'm looking at the
pages i'm looking at
pictures of pages in a book from this
church
on ancestry in my house here in north
carolina right
never knowing that i was going to go to
germany and hold
that book and look at the pages in my
hands
of those same books that are that i'm
using to trace my
genealogy right it was crazy they made
me put on these white gloves and all
this stuff to hold the books
this is the real deal but i went
there for my 40th birthday it was like
this sort of
game i had with myself that i was going
to go drink a beer
in that town on my 40th birthday and it
just so happened that i'd
met i was wanting to marry amy too
so i asked her if she would uh marry me
in that church in that town
um so that was a that was a pretty
incredible experience and we've
we've uh i think you know between the
australia trip
going to germany that really has
inspired me to kind of see more of the
of the world and just take in the beauty
of all those locations across this
world it's just an amazing place i i
want to see
i want to see some of it i don't have to
see it all but i want to see a lot more
of it
yeah yeah i mean you're speaking my
language i love
traveling there's so many places to go
and so many places to see in the world
when people ask what my favorite
destination is i'm like
the one i haven't been to yet because
there's just so much to see but i will
say new zealand is
is um really beautiful and the culture
is great and they're super fun
people it's kind of like it's kind of
like australia um but
i definitely would recommend going there
um
you were mentioned like going back in
history it makes me think of the new
show that you have called lost speedways
you're so nostalgic are you would you
call yourself nostalgic
yes super duper and he's worried like
his story is a nostalgic historian
especially for racing
or does that go everywhere is it for
everything because i guess it could be
for everything
well so i got i got sort of uh
i kind of got enamored with um
mystery and abandoned
uh places uh ships
sunk into the bottom of the sea you like
ghosts then too
yeah sort of yeah i mean if the if
there's a ghost story i guess that adds
to the mystique so you're gonna
choose to stay at the haunted house at
the haunted haunted hotel oh yeah
oh great yeah not me i would yeah for
sure
um i uh yeah i've kind of always just
been curious about this
you know there's there's so many places
all over the world that are just
hiding in the hiding in the woods you
know this the nature's re
reclaimed a lot of this stuff it might
be an amusement park
that's abandoned or some giant
infrastructure that was built for war
two
or whatever i don't know um but i like
to
i want to see them i want to go look at
them i want to go walk around in them
and see
what's going on so i've always kind of
been that way and about 10 years ago i
started to get
uh interested in finding abandoned race
tracks
and only the tracks where there's still
some
evidence of the track itself on the
location of the whole property
whether it's essentially it's not tore
down like you can still see the track
yeah if it's been redeveloped or
anything i'm not that interested in it
but i want to go to the places that are
still
there even if it's just a little bit um
i started a map on google about
12 years ago locating these tracks and
marking this map and i'm
and and i joined a a few other guys that
were doing the same thing and we've got
about 2
000 race tracks you've got like you're
on ancestry.com for racetracks
yes and so we really have a lot of
material if we want to continue to do
this show but we got eight episodes this
season
lost speedways um if it's on peacock tv
which is a new streaming platform for
nbc
yeah it's free my favorite show is like
yellowstone is on peacock so i know it
is
well i am not behind the paywall if you
want to see my show it's free download
the app and
and let's go watch away we're having fun
with it
yeah that's really cool it also makes me
think of um
the fact that you just got nominated for
the hall of fame
oh congratulations i know that's i don't
know
yes like that's your career you got
nominated for
does that hit you or is that just
something like what
what was the emotion or what's your what
did that what did you think when you're
when you got nominated well when you
hear it it made you want to cry but
um so i mean just happy tears but uh
yeah
i still i can't i can't figure out what
it means
uh i can't really underst i can't really
uh
it ha and it won't
uh it probably won't really make any
sense to me until i'm
in that moment i guess up on up on stage
giving that speech or
or putting that jacket on around the
other hall of famers that'll be there in
attendance and
going through that experience i think is
when it might kind of finally
make sense um
[Music]
you know i look at my numbers and i'm i
like uh
they you know they're right there uh you
know and i i see i saw all the guys that
were in that
um in that in that list of possible
uh nominees and you know they're all
amazing and
and my numbers are all kind of right
there with those guys and so
it made me feel good but um
i don't know you know i don't know i
never got to win a championship in the
cup series
and that
doesn't really haunt me every day but
it's a it's a
elation and a celebration i just didn't
get to experience so i can't
you know can't compare it to anything
else i know what running a race feels
like
and all those things and winning a
championship index finished series and
but never a cup series championship and
so
you know i guess this is a this is kind
of
going to be the icing on the cake
instead of championship it'll be this
hall of fame nomination and it's sort of
a
tip of the cap i guess from the industry
that that you mattered and
uh you you were an asset and you left a
mark
yeah are you gonna cry are you a crier
oh probably yeah i'm pretty sensitive
so i think that um i think i'll have a
hard time in some spots
in that in that speech for sure well
that resonates with people so
nobody wants to cry but if you start
crying
i guarantee there'll be like a million
people out there crying with you
tears of joy thank yeah i can't wait i
hope that uh you know considering
everything going on in the world
um you know it's been a it's been a
weird
couple of years but uh you know the hall
of fame
nomination for me and my personal life
certainly stands out as
as a as a highlight yeah you know
it should you deserve it thank you
thanks for doing this dale yeah i
appreciate it it's a lot of fun catching
up
yeah i know we didn't talk a ton of
racing but you know
whatever you want to talk about the
personal stuff is so interesting and
you're such a
you're such an interesting guy and you
have so many great stories and you're so
open and you know that's not always the
most common thing to find especially
with us drivers who are so
used to like buy the book cookie cutter
thank your sponsors and keep it short
and sweet like
it's um you um
well we can all recreate our personality
in any way we want and i
i would never describe you as being
introverted
awkward or uncomfortable or any of those
things so
you know i don't know if that's what you
wanted to accomplish but you have and so
you know you're not that that kid
anymore you're uh
you're an amazing father now
father and husband and um
hall of famer well thank you danica
i appreciate you being so kind um you've
been a great friend
uh and it's so good to see you catch up
with you
um always wondering what you're up to
and and where you are in life
i know you're all over the place doing
some amazing things so
you're fun to fun to keep up with a
little challenging to keep up with but
uh well we're always we're always
thinking about you oh thanks
thanks so i'll have to bring some bring
some wine around i make quite a bit of
it now so
would love to try oh my gosh i'm having
flashbacks to that
party in your backyard a few oh no oh
the boat was really fun too i was
actually just reminiscing about the boat
one where
amy and myself and a couple other girls
we were like in we were so
hammered and we were oh yeah it was
raining and we were always like standing
in the rain at the front of the boat
but i was also remembering being in your
backyard and having a party in the
backyard and we drank way too much
i don't even remember and you could have
like a fun boomerang picture of us in
the backyard
many two too many way too many drinks i
know i felt that the next day but
um you know i know there's more
responsibilities now with kids and
things like that but
that doesn't mean we don't know how to
have fun we know how to have fun if we
need to
all right let's do it all right thanks
dale
thank y'all thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button